[Music]
on this thursday night rethinking the
back to school routine
from class sizes to safety protocols the
confusion for students parents and
teachers
staff have no idea how they're supposed
to keep kids safe
plus covid19 conundrum the woman who
keeps testing positive
and has no symptoms american police
under fire again
when i saw the video it was very
disturbed
the arrest of a black man being called a
cold-blooded murder
peddling forward to freedom the canadian
invention revolutionizing life
for people with spinal cord injuries and
pitch
perfect impersonator
the parrot spreading its wings as a pop
diva
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with one of the biggest
challenges in reopening the economy in
the age of covet
september means back to school and that
means teachers parents and
millions of students are embarking on an
experiment what happens when you send
kids to class in a pandemic
some are still unsure about whether it's
worth the risk even the prime minister
said a few weeks ago
his family hadn't decided he has since
revealed his three kids will be back in
their classrooms and
posted this on twitter today his
youngest son hadrian
heading to grade one back to school
plans whether it's in class
online or a blended version of the two
and class
size and spacing varies depending on
where you live
in some regions officials want kids back
in class in person full time
in others like ontario students have the
option of remote learning
schools there will gradually reopen over
the next two weeks
we're ready and i'm not saying that
there's not going to be bumps there will
be bumps
in the road as sure as i'm standing here
but again
i have the confidence in the system the
teachers the principals and
the school boards not everyone is
sharing that confidence
in tonight's top story eric sorenson
takes a closer look at ontario
and the complex back to school rollout
how are you feeling about sending your
kids back to school i'm a little nervous
matthew boardman speaks for a lot of
parents
uneasy about sending their kids to
school cover 19 is not a joke
but at the same time life needs to get
back to normal for everybody
kimberly de ross has made a difficult
decision for her seven-year-old
and she's not alone i've chosen to to
keep him home with me i've actually quit
my job to do that
so he's going to be home we're going to
see what the you know the first couple
weeks look like or months look like
schools like ord street school in
toronto will be little more than half
full but many teachers are concerned
that class sizes will remain large
kids at my school will be coming to
school with large class sizes
no social distancing
and just unsafe conditions the basic
formula in an ordinary school year
classrooms full of kids each with a
teacher but many kids in ontario are
being kept out by their parents opting
to have them learn from home
however class sizes won't automatically
become smaller
in many cases students will be
redistributed to retain
standard size classes and teachers will
be reassigned
some to teach online the kids staying
home leaving some classrooms empty
and a last minute shuffle for teachers a
week and a half before the kids show up
in our classrooms
we not only know who our students are we
also don't know what grade or what
subject
and it's all up in the air i have all
the confidence and all the principals
and teachers going back to school
they're going to be the backbone of this
program bottom line say some premiers
there isn't enough money to make classes
smaller
take alberta which wants all kids in
classrooms there is no
uh world in which you could reduce class
sizes in half and reopen the schools for
the current school year
you'd have to build 800 new schools and
certify 13 000 new teachers
it's simply fictitious
back in ontario administrators say it's
a lot of change so close to the school
year
yes this is very late in the game but
teachers are
professionals and given the time and the
support
they will be very good teachers wherever
it is they end up teaching
opening schools is only the start
teaching and learning will only get more
complicated
if and when covet 19 shows up in
classrooms
eric sorensen global news toronto
parents and teachers in new brunswick
found out today what back to school will
look like for them
that province released its operational
plans they're all available online
each school developed individual
approaches based on student population
facilities and community needs full-time
learning will be mandatory for all
students
whether they're in class or at home in
newfoundland and labrador the provincial
government is creating new virtual
teaching positions to help
immuno compromise students who can't
attend school
and more public health nurses will be
hired for added support
everyone is being encouraged to use the
covid19
alert app which lets users know if
they've been close to someone who's
tested positive for the virus
newfoundland and labrador is the first
province in atlantic canada
to launch that app nova scotia's back to
school objective is to return
to full capacity in the fall when
classes resume next week
but the nova scotia teachers union is
raising major concerns about the
province's back to school strategy
as ross lord reports time is running out
to get it right
when classrooms in nova scotia open next
week van bernard won't be there
it's a little bit upsetting that i can't
see all my friends
but i'm happy that i'm home because i
don't think i'd feel
safe and secure if i were at school
van has spinal muscular atrophy he uses
a machine
several times a day to clear his lungs
of matter that could make him sick
i would need one of my helpers to
take off my mask if i were in school and
be very very close to me and put it on
my face
when he gets the flu typically he ends
up in the hospital with double lung
pneumonia
a two week stay full antibiotics
ivs breathing machines so
i can't even fathom what kovod would
look like for him
the nova scotia teachers union is also
sounding the alarm
claiming conditions and policies for
resuming classes
are sorely lacking the union says
opening day
scheduled for next tuesday should be
delayed there's no sanitizer for staff
to train with
there are no safety protocols in place
so schools are chaos right now
i mean staff have no idea how they're
supposed to keep kids safe
the nova scotia government insists
there's a practical plan in place
a plan that includes removing students
who might be infected
there's some anxiety associated with
that no question uh but
but you know the the rhetoric around
schools being in chaos is just not
helpful not accurate
van and his family say there's no
reassurance about protecting
the most vulnerable students nobody
seems to know
anything about how to social distance or
how to safely
integrate special needs children
in the classroom and in the resource
centers van's parents are not
experienced in homeschooling
but they say van will start grade 8 at
home until they're more confident he can
attend classes in person
safely ross lord global news hammonds
plains nova scotia
in quebec a group of parents has gone to
court to fight for the right to keep
their kids home to learn remotely in
quebec superior court the group said new
back to school rules in the province are
unfairly restrictive
they want an injunction issue to allow
more students the option to learn from
home
right now only students who qualify for
medical exemptions
can opt for virtual learning what we
need to keep an eye on as schools reopen
is case numbers and right now
they are rising in quebec and across the
country 187
more people tested positive in quebec
today that is the largest daily jump
since july next door in ontario there
were more than 100 new infections
reported today for the eighth straight
day
cases are also going up in western
canada there were 130 new cases in
alberta today and
89 in bc a montreal woman is having
trouble getting her life back to normal
because of covid19
she has no symptoms though she's tested
positive for the virus
more than half a dozen times the story
of her confusing case
is coming up a little later first though
to the united states the mayor of
rochester new york is suspending the
officers involved in the arrest of a
black man who died after being
restrained by police in march
daniel prude who had a history of mental
illness died of his fixation
police had put what's called a spit hood
over his head to keep him from spitting
on them
a warning the video is disturbing prude
was naked
and agitated rochester's mayor says
what he needed was help mr prue
lost his life in our city
he lost his life because of the actions
of our police officers
he lost his life because of the failure
of a lot of different
systems on that day it happened march 23
in rochester this week the family
released part of the body cam video
obtained
from police it shows the 41 year old
running naked through the streets before
being handcuffed by the police who then
cover his head
with a spit hood at the time kovid 19
was out of control in new york
the video shows officers push him face
down onto the ground and
hold him there until he becomes
unresponsive
he was taken to hospital and died a week
later
if it was a police officer
who was assaulted
this would have came out the same day
[Music]
and it would have been on the news
every day and every hour
it would have came out as soon as it
happened
but black people's lives are devalued
the medical examiner has ruled prude's
death a homicide caused by complications
of asphyxia
in the setting of physical restraint
excited delirium and drug intoxication
the mayor said today prude was failed by
the police department
the mental health care system society
and by her
the case of another unarmed black man
jacob blake who was shot in the back by
officers in kenosha wisconsin
was in the spotlight again today
democratic presidential candidate joe
biden
went to kenosha he met lake's family and
went to a community gathering to address
the recent civil unrest
biden says that unrest is not entirely
president trump's fault but that trump
has
legitimized a dark side of human nature
jackson proskow reports today it was joe
biden's turn to visit kenosha
where he met privately with the family
of jacob blake the wisconsin man shot
seven times in the back by police blake
joined by phone from his hospital bed
he talked about how nothing was going to
defeat him
how whether he walked again or not he
was not going to give up
later at a public meeting the former
vice president pushed a message of
healing and unity
you have to take responsibility if
you're
a leader a president two days ago
the current president visited the city
without acknowledging the reasons for a
wave of protests
that at times have turned violent the
fact is that
we've seen tremendous violence and we
will put it out very very quickly if
given the chance
polls show americans trust biden more
than trump to tackle issues of policing
and criminal justice
the former vp is also well ahead with
likely voters in wisconsin
and elsewhere up eight points here nine
points in arizona
and four points in north carolina send
it in early
where on wednesday trump suggested his
supporters should think about voting
twice
by mail and in person you send them in
but you go to vote
and if they haven't counted it you can
vote so that's the way i view it
voting twice is illegal but it's part of
trump's strategy to so doubt about the
validity of an election that may come
down to the wire
a survey of major polls found that on
average biden is 7.3 percent ahead of
trump nationally
far ahead of where hillary clinton was
at this point in 2016.
generally speaking biden is also leading
in enough states to get over 270
electoral votes so
the person who needs the race to change
really is trump
it seems the republican and democratic
conventions barely move the needle for
either candidate
opinions are already baked in with few
left to win
over it seems this election will simply
come down to who turns out to vote
jackson absolutely nothing is certain in
this election what factors might be
working in trump's favor
well he's got the electoral college in
his corner donna and that means he could
actually lose the popular vote by a
wider margin than he did to hillary
clinton back in 2016
and still keep the presidency all if he
manages to flip and hold on to the right
states
all right still a long time between now
and november third jackson and
washington thanks
it's two months until the u.s
presidential election and social media
is playing a big role in how people
get their information we know that
facebook said today it will not accept
any new political ads
in the week before the u.s election
however nothing changes before that
and in the week before voting political
ads already running on facebook can
still have their target audience
adjusted
lies are still acceptable too facebook
will not fact check political ads
the company says it will remove posts
with misinformation on voting policies
and the kovid 19 pandemic in a facebook
post ceo mark zuckerberg said
this election is not going to be
business as usual and that
it means helping people register and
vote clearing up confusion about how
this election will work
and taking steps to reduce the chances
of violence and unrest
facebook's restrictions on political ads
will lift
the day after the election biking
through
barriers coming up the canadian
invention helping people with spinal
cord injuries
there's still so much we don't
understand about covid19 and the
mysteries are deeply frustrating
tonight we have the story of a quebec
healthcare worker who has tested
positive multiple times
the first time was in may and since then
every test she's taken
has come back positive she's never
actually been sick but as mike armstrong
explains the virus
has put her life on hold i don't know
where else to start other than
how frustrating is this it's very
frustrating
it's very frustrating but also very
stressful
when she first tested positive for
covid19 sarah larascottie thought she'd
be fine in a couple of weeks
that first test came back may 6th but as
an
orderly at this montreal seniors
residence to be allowed back to work she
needed
two negative tests she hasn't been able
to get even
one you go back and get tested again and
again and again
and every time it comes back positive
yeah how many times
so far uh eight times so far
eight times eight times positive yeah
well keeping a positive attitude hasn't
been easy cotes had some ups and downs
in june doctors told her she wasn't
contagious and allowed her to go back to
work
and school she's studying nursing at
this sajap but after another test
last week she was told it had been so
long that she was now considered as
having been
re-infected that caused some problems
when she told the school
it sent 50 of her fellow students home
they asked them to quarantine either for
two weeks or to come back with a
negative result
because of you yeah this kind of yes no
positive or negative is not so helpful
anymore this epidemiologist
says cote likely isn't contagious what's
showing up in the tests
is probably dead particles of the virus
inactive and
not dangerous he says the longer the
pandemic is around
the more cases like cotes will see
this is part of the reason why we change
the policy that we don't
ask for people to have negative tests
now we go by time-based and clinical
criteria
how's your family doing they're stressed
out
back in may cote was living with her
boyfriend he didn't catch it
now she's living in her parents home
along with her grandparents no one's
caught it there either
but she does know what covid19 can mean
back in april and may the virus ripped
through the senior's residence where she
was working
it was hard there was like almost nobody
there to help us
it was very hard and people died yeah
the lady the resident who i think i got
the covet from was tested positive she
passed away
yeah a lot yeah it's very sad coltay
says one of the things that's made it
easier for her to cope
is remembering how many people have had
it worse than her
mike armstrong global news mirabel
quebec
still ahead the search for survivors
after a cargo ship sinks
near japan
a search is under way off japan where a
massive ship carrying 43 crew and
thousands
of cattle has capsized one person was
rescued last night by a japanese navy
aircraft
42 others are still missing the
panamanian ship was transporting 5 800
cows from new zealand to china
when it hit extreme weather brought on
by typhoon
maisuk a couple of new appointments of
note in canada today the canadian space
agency has a new
president lisa campbell who was
associate deputy minister of veterans
affairs she becomes the first female
president of the space
agency and brad ragier is the new
president of the canadian bar
association the first time an indigenous
person has held that position
regier is a partner in a winnipeg law
firm
next how a bike became a lifeline for
two albertans with spinal cord injuries
a spinal cord injury can change life in
just seconds
and now a calgary man injured in a
skiing accident has invented
an ingenious machine in his basement
it's a bike that's given him and others
mobility they feared
they'd lost jamie dahl has the story
just two and a half years ago j.p
middleton's life took a giant pivot
it's a feeling of absolute helplessness
you're lying there and you can't move
your lower body you know
i i couldn't lift myself up i was stuck
in one position and i'm now at the hands
of you know the people that i was once
working with
the former first responder instantly
knew his own daunting fate
the moment his body hit the ground after
a crash skiing
terrifying absolutely terrifying you
start thinking about the future before
before even in the ambulance you think
of your family you're thinking of
your jobs you're thinking of life going
forward
the bath dad of two spent months in the
hospital trying to navigate his new
normal
and then one day he saw something one of
my darkest days there
back at the hospital and heard this
whizzing sound go past me i looked up
and it was
this mad max looking vehicle when i saw
this bike i thought
i'd gotta get myself one of these things
it was a ray of hope for me
a big part of the experience that i
wanted was to go
mountain biking with my friends just go
out and have
fun with them christian begg was the guy
on that bike
he is the mastermind behind the bow head
reach an all-terrain bike with an
articulating front end
and electric motor that will go anywhere
it's an integral part of the
experience because now you can keep up
with people on a bike
bag also suffered a spinal cord injury
on the slopes of bamf
he started building the bikes and now
riders include children
and even former pro athletes going
beyond what they thought
possible they want to just go where
they used to go people will be doing
like giant like motocross size ramps
or they'll be going out with their
family or they'll be
you know going fishing for the first
time in five years like the
the scope of what people do on it is
insane
it's become an extension of my body you
know i take this bike
everywhere with me i need this to keep
up for my voice
middleton says the bike not only
restored his freedom
it's also led to a cherished friendship
through the most difficult days of his
life
from someone who has been there too he's
taught me just to persevere
to stay you know forward driven
to to to conquer all your fears
and to move forward in life no matter
how rough the path
that lies ahead jamie dawg global news
banff alberta love that story
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen we leave you
tonight with a parrot
parody
[Music]
okay so that's beyonce performing her
hit if i were a boy
and here's chico the parrot
nine-year-old chico lives in a british
wildlife park and is now taking
requests thanks for watching hope to see
you here again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye